[Music]
you will forever be our doll
now
sashay away
thank you so much for the platform
uplifting the drag queens and giving us
voice well i did not expect this at all
i'm still processing it i don't know
which cloud i am at this point but i'm
still trying to find it
a lot of height a lot of low and a lot
of emotion so i think i feel good i mean
i committed to what i believe was the
right thing to do and i do not regret
anything and that's the most important
part listen
i think you did your job in snatch game
you went viral too
because me in my time i went viral to
post nude you left people confused and i
think that's part of what yoko does well
nobody really understands yoko no you
know what i mean so choosing her was a
let's call it a smart choice because
it's a little bit more in-depth and just
a little more intellectual but at the
same time i knew not a lot of people are
gonna understand it so i'm not surprised
but i i thought it was funny it's
subjective right and then we get to the
lip sync and let me tell you watching
the lip sync i know eve you're both
fantastic performers
i think you won that lip
sync today
i was so shocked it's just like you know
things go so quickly so you don't even
have time to process where you're at and
then you're like okay say your last word
is like one last word i'm not done
so i guess i was shocked i want a little
tea from you so if you were not
if you were not going to be in the
bottom yesterday who would you have put
in the bottom two alongside eve six
thousand well tell us if you wanted to
be shady you have to listen to all my
confessions
honestly i thought adriana was going to
be in bottom with eve adriana
you are safe you may join the other
queens
thank you so much but you know it's just
i trust the judges it's a good season
it's the judging is great also and you
know everybody's a professional like i
am
so uh it is what it was
you're representing you know the asian
drag artist community with this show and
you spoke about the difficulty of being
even booked as a asian drag performer
which in my mind in 2021 is absolutely
ridiculous moving forward how do we
change this mindset of people who do
these bookings to include the asian drag
community i think we have as much to
offer as many other artists and it's
just of course that when i was speaking
about a little bit more specific to
quebec because you know it's such a
small community at the work it's really
to just like be more open to listen and
also leave the stage for people to
you know understand other cultures and
heritage because sometimes the type of
jokes that they land is a little bit
awkward for people who are of color uh
the by popular community and that
doesn't leave you you know an
atmospheric environment that's safe for
new artists to emerge i'm one of the
only artists in the past like two
decades we had three asian dracules
queens before max because they're not
performing anymore but that's not normal
i mean like one
two of us in past two decades it's very
little